[Music]
thank you I really enjoyed Walker's
comments I would take that all to heart
that's a really good good information
for you so I'm just going to tell you
kind of the quick story of Pandora the
circuitous path we took to get here and
maybe in sort of our experience there
might be things that you will find
interesting or helpful in your own
journeys I can just sense the
entrepreneurial energy in this room when
I was walking through the lobby on the
way and it was like humming it's really
fun to be around so I went to to school
Stanford I was I'm gonna grad there and
I studied Poli Sci which is Stanford's
shortest major which allowed me to do a
lot of different things as an undergrad
and I have had a lifelong passion for
music and it really burgeoned when I was
in college and when I graduated I knew I
wanted to be involved with music in some
capacity I didn't really know how how I
was gonna make a living at it and I was
completely unprepared for any kind of
job given my Poli Sci degree so hunted
around and found up getting a job as a
nanny that's a respectable profession
actually mani is the proper term for
that and I was a mani for the first five
years after school that was my job it's
not really what my parents expected when
I graduated college but kids are my
other lifelong passion so for the first
five years after school of my life
consisted of getting up in the morning
sitting down at the piano and playing
piano till about 1:00 or 2:00 in the
afternoon and then going to pick up
these two kids nine ten-year-old boys at
elementary school taking them home and
hanging out in the afternoon playing
wiffle ball on the street with a bunch
of kids and making sure they did their
homework
I've been cooking dinner for the family
and then coming home getting back on the
piano and playing so I went to bed so I
was playing piano 810 hours a day and
then hanging out with kids pretty good
life did that for a while and then wound
up getting involved in rock bands it's
been about seven eight years living out
of a van being sort of part of this huge
sea of
I think a lot of talented but completely
invisible working musicians and
eventually kind of grew tired of that
and then wound up a film go film
composer writing music for picture
started with sort of small short student
films and kind of gradually worked my
way into doing sort of independent
feature films it took a few years so I
was coming this winding road and and
over the course of that experience as a
musician a bunch of ideas began to kind
of accumulate in my head one was of
course all this undiscovered incredible
music that I'd experienced was seen as a
musician and then as a film composer my
job as a composer really first and
foremost is to figure out the taste of a
film director and the way we would do
that and I developed sort of
methodologies I would sit with a
director and we would actually watch a
the completed locked picture with sound
effects and dialogue but no music on it
and I would bring with me a stack of CDs
and I would play songs for them and we
would talk about the music and it was
sort of give me their feedback to it and
I would use that musical interview kind
of like a musical myers-briggs test to
sort of glean from them what they wanted
in the score for their films I'd go back
and compose something so I developed a
musical logical profile of their taste
and I did this for a few years and and
and then one day I read an article a
newspaper that literally kind of a light
went off in my head and I thought maybe
I could codify this taste profiling I
was doing and turn it into a technology
by marrying it to math and build an
algorithm that would allow people to
discover songs connect songs based on
the music illogical attributes so this
taxonomy I had been kind of forming in
my brain as a film composer that I would
actually write it down and use that as a
connective tissue and that could become
sort of the solution for people
discovering all these great bands that
nobody knew about
so in 1999 so is the sort of apex of the
first big calm consumer calm boom
I shared that here with a friend of mine
who had already by then started and sold
a company so I've been through the whole
lifecycle of a start-up and named John
Kraft and he said hey that's like go
ahead you let's go start a company I
said well how do you do that he said
what's the write a business plan along
what's how you do that I'll show you so
we spent a weekend put together a
business plan and about two months later
had a million and a half dollars that
was how it was done back then to launch
a business and the the cornerstone of
the idea was this what we came to call
the Music Genome Project which was this
enormous taxonomy fits squarely into the
completely unscalable idea that Walker
share with you before this the genome is
a 450 attribute list of musicals of
musical taxonomy that essentially
captures every little detail of melody
and harmony and rhythm and form
instrumentation voice etcetera it's
kinda like musical DNA and it's a
gigantic list and we wrote it out and
hired a few dozen musicians to come in
and listen to songs one at a time and
manually analyze them attribute by
attribute assign a number to every song
to collect musical DNA and hired a set
of computer scientists to attach to that
essentially an algorithm that could use
that information to connect songs based
on their musical proximity and we began
to that turns about a year to build the
first prototype and we literally did it
on pencil and paper at first
I kid you not we had ultimately about 75
musicians scribbling on paper and then
we transferred that into Microsoft Excel
and a year into our this project we
built our prototype we had analyzed
about 10,000 songs and our founding CTO
wil Glaser had written an Excel macro
that would allow us to compute the
distance between any of these 10,000
songs the way it worked is you would
pick one of the songs enter it into the
search box and hit rank and the the
macro would rank order least 10,000
songs by proximity about musical
proximity to your source song
so a year into this we give this thing a
first spin we type in a Beatle song and
we wait about three or four minutes for
the macro to do his calculation and it
out comes a list and the first song is a
BG song and like oh you know
doesn't work after all this time you
know and believe me as entrepreneurs you
will have many moments like that but
listen to the track and it was uncannily
similar to a Beatle song it turned out
it was a very very early Bee Gees song
at a time when as a band they were more
or less a knockoff of the Beatles
so it had found the perfect match among
these 10,000 songs turns out so I went
from despair to elation in a very short
amount of time and realized you know
well it kind of works so we kind of
forged ahead kept analyzing more songs
and sort of refining that the front end
to this matching engine this was now
2001 though and and everything had gone
to hell in a handbasket the dot-com boom
had collapsed the music industry was in
complete shambles a Napster was at its
apex and in our first efforts to go
raise money it was pretty clear that was
not gonna be easy to do and so realizing
we don't have to make our money last we
began asking our employees in the course
of 2001 to work for an ever smaller
share of their salary until by the end
of 2001 we weren't paying employees at
all we call that salary deferral back
then which incidentally is illegal in
California
apparently we couldn't afford an
attorney though we had no idea that we
were breaking the law and ultimately
about 50 people work without salary for
over two years to keep this thing going
and we we managed to make it through the
whole calm valley by essentially you
know this group of people that sort of
hung in there by the end of 2003 at 11
maxed out credit cards I think I owed
like half a million dollars a personal
debt and we owed close to two million
dollars of back salary to all these
employees five of whom were actually
suing us for having done that
I also had a personal obligation for
five years on a large commercial office
space in Auckland and I was a musician
you know so it wasn't like if it didn't
work out I'd go back to my lucrative
band days and pay it all back quickly it
was gonna be Mexico for me for sure
we we hung in there and eventually after
I'd pitch Pandora 348 times I found a
series Beauty investor in 2004 March of
o4 raised a nine million dollar round
which I still don't quite know how it
happened and we paid out two million
dollars with salary that day we actually
had an All Hands meeting which I will
never forget we had All Hands meetings
every two weeks at this time they were
generally not very happy occasions
because I was just asking people to work
for two more weeks for no salary and
this one and no one knew the money had
come in the night before so when I sat
down rather than giving my pitch to sort
of two more weeks of sacrifice I pulled
out of my back pocket this huge wad of
envelopes and slapped them down the
table and handed out like two million
dollars a salary but much of your on the
table everybody thought I was like you
know it was a really bad joke was going
to bounce or something but I paid
everybody back yeah and we were able
essentially to restart the business and
went from really kind of this forlorn
business we had not figured out how to
make any money at it but we had built
this really cool piece of IP this
gigantic musical taxonomy and this
matching engine that was a really killer
you type in a song and it would send you
back five tunes that were just
remarkably similar and maybe three or
four which you'd never heard before so
it was like it's magical discovery box
and then we what set about sort of
figuring out what to do next and that's
when the company took a big right-hand
turn and repurposed that whole
underlying technology and built this
brand new thing that we came to call
Pandora and we've launched that in the
fall of 2005 in November of five
actually we did a prototype with some
friends and family and then launched it
as a fully blown free service to the
public in November of five and I just
took off like a rocket ship and has not
you know not stopped and it was you know
we went from this bizarre a night
experience it was not glamorous to this
to be quite the opposite you know just
experiencing this completely viral
explosion that was propelled by the
smartphone revolution of course which
came to the summer of 2007 and we went
from having you know 50 employees to now
1,700 and 50 offices and three countries
around the world and it's a really
incredible experience of course to go
through that and one thing I want to
talk a little bit about in this context
you today is you know I think that one
thing that the reason I'm still here and
this company is still around which which
has it has no business being I mean the
the chances our company having survived
that are close to zero when we raise our
second amount of financing I think one
out of a thousand companies was getting
money and I get asked a lot of well you
know how did this company survive all
that and I think one of the key things
was that we always had a very clear
sense of purpose inside the business
there was a reason why we were doing
this that we all I think really believed
in which was sort of two-sided coin one
was that you know music is this magical
thing that we all love but most people
have a very hard time staying connected
to it music especially as you get older
radio doesn't not play the music you
love and it's very time consuming to
interact with it when you get a job it's
hard to really have that time you get
kind of connected from it but when you
reconnect to music it's a powerful thing
and we really believed in what we were
doing so the good we could bring people
by helping them enjoy that and the flip
side of that coin is what we could do
for artists they would be providing this
platform that for the first time would
start to surfacing music and playing it
in a way it's completely blind to
popularity which is again the
cornerstone of the genome project so the
music genome when it when it connects
one song to another it doesn't know if
that song it's playing is from a
well-known established artist or some
brand new band it's blind to that so
it's a completely democratic sort of
level playing field and we play about a
hundred and forty thousand artists or so
I think in our in our catalog just about
every single artist plays every month on
this service and there are 12,000
artists now
Pandora that have at least 350,000 a
unique listeners on the service that
have created a station using their name
to start it 12,000 and of those 12,000
about 80% have never played on any form
of radio ever so it's this huge sea of
what I think of as a the future
musicians middle class that has been out
there all this time but no one's been
able to find them and our ambition is
really to surface them and give them a
future and I think throughout this
process even when things were in their
darkest moments that was something that
I think sort of kept us all together and
when this when the server when the
company began to really grow a post
launch of as Pandora I could see the
company begin to evolve lots of exciting
ways but I also knew that we needed to
really hang on to something special that
sort of that tap root that had kept us
alive during those times and that I
thought would be really important for us
as we grew to maintain the integrity of
the business and so we actually sat down
and crafted what we call Pandora
principles there are now seven of them
and these principles are really kind of
a statement about why we're around who
we are what we care about you know how
we treat each other the sort of cultural
values if you will of the company and we
imbue those into the business we really
do take pains to hire based on them to
fire based on them to promote based on
them and everybody who comes into the
company we hire about 70 or 80 people a
month right now it's blows my mind and
actually go through what call Pandora
University which is a day-and-a-half
set of sessions the capstone session of
which is really is called Pandora
principles where we talk people through
this and teach them about it and and
ensure that when they go into the
company they absorb sort of and adopt
these principles because I really have a
huge belief that you know no matter how
much of a head start you have how strong
your brand is you know how good your
fundamentals are as a business if you
don't have a really firm grasp on the
core principles and culture of your
company you will eventually hit the
rocks and I think that's true of
companies that just about any stage
certainly in small start
you have two or three founders there's
ample opportunity for things to go south
and it's really important to do good
housekeeping to keep your cultural house
in order and I think that remains a real
big strength of the company so now as I
sort of look ahead and see what sort of
possible you know I my I consider myself
sort of the sort of Guardian of that
inside the company and I think having
sort of grown up the way we did over
these sort of kind of a pretty rough few
years in some ways we learned the value
of that and I would really encourage all
of you as you build your companies as
you grow them to not underestimate the
power of those things even as you have
all these exciting prospects ahead and
your audience is growing like tea
Springs is and you can see all that
opportunity to not forget the importance
of sort of the fabric of your business
how you treat each other the culture
building is ultimately that's what will
sustain you over a long period of time
I can't you see the timing so I don't
know am i doing okay I'm supposed to be
looking somewhere a timer am i okay
okay so I start a little bit early I'm
happy to take questions if people have
them I want to give a little time for
that too so
thanks Tim if you have any questions for
him come on down it's not only the front
and center question all right I when you
said you were trying to raise your
Series B and you you said that he didn't
have any idea of what the business model
would be how did you keep the people
working without a clear vision of how
you would make that work and how did you
get the investors to pitch in you had to
keep the employees around so they were
chained to their desks and we locked in
I think that there are a couple reasons
that Pandora stuck around one as I said
is this real sense of belief and a
common purpose and a mission that was
really important and this product that
we all thought was pretty magical and
that we could hang around long enough
would would find its home the second is
I think there's a phenomena that happens
when you go through adversity one of two
things happens either you scatter or you
kind of come together and you actually
start to work to sort of sustain
yourselves kind of for each other I
think that's part of would have happened
at Pandora over the months as we began
to do her salary month after month after
a month it became you know you felt a
certain obligation to people around you
to contemplate saying to the person on
your left you've been doing it for a
year or one day you know what I'm done
that just felt really hard to do so I
think that was that was part of it as
well and I certainly learned to be a
motivational leader and if there's one
piece of advice I would give to every
single one of you about entrepreneurship
it's learned public speaking and I don't
mean learn to be able to talk in front
of a large audience of people I mean
just learn to speak learn to communicate
to groups of all sizes and to be able to
communicate an idea with passion with
vision because no matter what you do no
matter what your product is no matter
what size your company is that will come
in tremendously handy so you know that
was part of it too when you had like two
million dollars of outstanding wages how
are you actually keeping everyone on I
mean just ENTJ on myers-briggs and
you're that convincing or how does that
go okay again I think it's it's um I did
pay salaries on my credit card for a
while which I don't recommend
I don't recommend credit card debt I
remember one day being in my living room
Ashley and laying out all my credit
cards on the table filled the table up
and I was trying to like sequence my
minimum payments it was like a Tetris
game like trying to figure out what to
pay first not a good experience do not
use your credit cards for your startup
that was a bad mistake I think that I
was the first to defer salary you know I
you lead by example you know you like to
first in last out that's how you gotta
do it yeah I think all the questions of
center around how you convince 50 people
did not take salaries in two years will
you just imagine this crowd as the 50
employees and give that pitch that you
gave and also talk about how how you
evolve that pitch over time that's
hard
how do that now that pitch you know what
if I go back to that time I'll start
shaking and sweating and get all nervous
and my heart will pound I might not give
the whole play - let me tell you what I
would focus on I would say that we all
know here that what we've created is
unique and it's solving a gigantic
problem no one in the unearthed is
Vindhya we've done and when you use this
product we all know how magical it is it
will find its home everybody in the
planet loves music there are millions of
musicians that produce great music and
they can't find each other when this
thing finally finds its home it's gonna
change culture and how many times in
your life to get a chance to do that
that's what this is about
they work
and so that pitch stay consistent
through no look I mean part of it part
of it is a pitching but part of is also
leaning into each employee one by one
taking them to lunch dinner
understanding their problems empathizing
with it really you know being close to
them getting to know them getting to
trust you that's really where it all
starts yeah when you had made the Music
Genome Project you struggled for a while
to figure out what Pandora was gonna
become what else could it have been what
was the reaction it could have been in a
big smoking hole in the ground for a
long time
well our original idea was we thought we
would license it as a technology to
everybody else so whether you're a
retailer or ultimately a radio product
that you could use the genome as a
ingredient technology so it's kind of
like the power bi and we actually did
license into a handful of companies to
do that but it turns out it's not a very
good business and music retails and
under such pressure we couldn't really
generate a much revenue for it that's
really what we were doing for a long
time yeah so in the interest of time
we'll take these last three hi Jen
thanks so much for sharing your insight
and being here I'm volunteer for hustle
on my question is you know I'm new to
the startup game and I want to know when
is it appropriate to make pivots and
when is it appropriate to you know stay
committed to your idea that's a tough
question to answer with sort of a set of
rules because on the one hand I think
that successful startups require a
certain kind of irrational commitment to
an idea that many people look at and say
that's crazy it'll never work
I mean the genome was that idea when we
when I did my adventure pitches you know
I would show them a PowerPoint set of
powerpoints and one sly would be one of
seven pages of musical analysis these
attributes that I would explain yeah we
have human beings doing it one by one
takes 20 minutes do with three minute
pops on and look at me what the is
wrong with you you know like you kidding
me
you're gonna fund this and it was crazy
I mean it was it was flat-out crazy has
an idea and a lot of people just do you
off course
so you have to have a certain irrational
singular belief and be stubborn about it
but I also think that you should be open
to discovering new opportunities and so
I think that it's a combination of
believing in one idea but when things
present themselves yeah don't be overly
obsessively kind of stuck with your idea
that's the best I can tell you thank you
the first person stole my question so I
had to come up with second sitting here
my question for you is as you create a
platform you have this amazing vision
I'm for example I'm creating something
that I view is like gonna change the
world and you were plan is to bring
together thousands of artists or you
know whatever it may be and you want to
create this collaborative platform where
you want to pay the artists you know for
their time for whatever they
collaborated and sold on the marketplace
how do you reach an equilibrium point
between making the artists happy because
a lot of artists are gonna say you're
paying me money for what I'm
producing and you're taking in all this
money and you have all this pressure of
investors etc how do you reach that that
peaceful point so I think these things
need to be seen with a long-term lens
and I think music industry's going
through it numbers of industries have
already gone through which is sort of a
period of constructive destruction
they're changing and I think the
long-term view the long-term vision of
the industry that we think everyone will
come together around is it will music
will exist on a connected platform so it
will not be broadcast radio or you you
play a song it goes out to the ether you
even know who's listening to it when
what they think of it they're
disconnected to a platform where you're
sending that email that that that music
to people you know who they are you know
how they if they like it or don't and
you can communicate with them and you
will have access as a musician to all of
those fans directly and you will have
fantastic tools to communicate with them
so imagine this you're in your band
you're you're in a van your band driving
from San Francisco to Seattle to play a
show we used to do it all the time and
you just thought you know let's stop in
Portland tomorrow night and play
pull out your iPhone zoom into your
Pandora artist account log in zoom into
Portland look up how many listeners they
are thumbed up your songs or create a
station with your name record a
15-second Audio bumper on the phone
upload it the next 24 hours that message
plays to people in Portland that have
light your music or create a station
with a link to buy a ticket to that show
by the way we can already do that so
that over time is going to completely
transform the entire economics of the
business that's what people will come to
understand I think yeah thank you thanks
for your speech was so inspiring also
very entertaining community you know
we're fortunate all of us to be at this
time where people were working for
companies that are very mission driven
or we're creating companies we're very
people focused and it's awesome that
you're able to inspire 50 people to stay
on in that way how do you scale that you
know it's one thing to have a
conversation take 50 people out to get
to know them how do you scale among the
organization of 7,200 people that type
of people focus management and putting
people first and keeping people aligned
with the mission yeah so that's a big
focus for us right now because it one
person can do that six people can't
actually ultimately to sustain a culture
like that hundreds of people need to be
active advocates for that so we do a lot
of training now our sort of our next
evolution as a business is how do you
take the several hundred managers now
who imagine anywhere from 1 to 15 20
people and give them all the skills they
need to be equally powerful ambassadors
inside the company that's the task of
leaders and it's I think it's one of the
transitions that founders go through
over time is eventually in spite of what
Walker says he's not going to be
answering emails all day long and doing
he's gonna be pulled into other things
and he will teach other people to do
that as well as he did who will teach
other people to do that and it's it's
actually frustrating as a founder
because eventually feel like you're not
as connected as you were and you'll do
some of that to stay in touch with it
but your job becomes transmitting what
your your passion
and your ideas and values to other
people and helping them continue to do
that onward that's that's the transition
you go through alright thank you guys
very much
[Applause]